el alcalde de londres acaba de decretar
el estado de emergencia en la ciudad por
el aumento disparado de casos de
coronavirus al menos más de 7000
personas están siendo atendidas en este
momento en los centros hospitalarios de
la capital británica más de 800 personas
requieren ingresar a los hospitales por
este virus shalkan teme que si los casos
los contagios siguen aumentando como
hasta el momento récords históricos en
los últimos días en la última semana el
sistema de salud de la capital británica
puede estar colapsado en dos semanas es
tan grave la situación que no hay
capacidad de médicos de personal
sanitario para atender esta situación
que más de 100 bomberos de la ciudad
están manejando las ambulancias para
atender a las personas que requieren
esta medida extrema de ir al hospital
entretanto shadi khan le está pidiendo
al gobierno nacional que prohíba todas
las actividades que todavía se permiten
en medio de este confinamiento nacional
como la asistencia a lugares de culto a
lugares religiosos y que impongan
a partir de ahora el uso obligatorio de
mascarillas para salir a las casas y por
supuesto en lugares públicos esta es una
medida que todavía no es obligatoria en
la capital británica así que esa dedican
está pidiendo el gobierno nacional que
actúe de una manera rápida